hello good morning nate how is your  monday going  good morning sherry so far mostly sunny  but we are keeping an eye out for the  possibility of some wet roads we'll be  following the radar along with sherry  for now the overall traffic map looking  pretty good on your monday morning let's  head on down and oh boy it looks like we  got something that looks like it's super  busy down there in the southbound i-15  but i'm pretty sure that's our old  friend phantom  traffic because take a look at a live  picture now i-15  showing there are some cars in both  directions around blue diamond but  really not that much going on  so we're now going to move over to the  las vegas trip at flamingo  i believe that john langley is going to  be talking about this ongoing police  investigation around las vegas boulevard  and flamingo  all lanes are open on the strip right  now john indeed thank you very much we  do have that developing story this  morning  shots fired on the las vegas strip